ces femmes ces couples réunis dans sept
salles d'attentes sont quelques-uns des
cent mille adhérents des 252 centre du
mouvement français pour le planning
familial répartis dans toute la france
il/elle la branche français d'une
fédération internationale dont le centre
est à londres
son but contribuer à la prise de
conscience de la responsabilité du
couple devant la naissance d'un enfant
comment menez-vous donner l'adresse
alors au fond paix souhaitez-vous savoir
précisément connues sur tout dans le
grand public pour son action en faveur
de la contraception de la régulation des
naissances depuis quelques temps il a
pris une orientation un peu différente
il se propose une étude des problèmes de
la maternité de la natalité et de leurs
répercussions familiale sociale et
nationale et poursuit la recherche des
informations scientifiques ainsi qu'une
action en faveur de l'information et de
l'éducation qui peut contribuer pour une
bonne femme au développement harmonieux
de la famille ceci bien sûr dans le
respect de la liberté de chacun
d'assumer les responsabilités de sa vie
sexuelle et affective
le planning familial à de nombreuses
activités
c'est ainsi par exemple que des
conseillers d'information sexuelles et
des médecins du collège médical du ganil
familiale répondre à toutes les demandes
de conférences et d'animations de groupe
les assistantes comme ici sont chargés
de recevoir et d'informer chacun qu'ils
soient jeunes ou moins jeunes mariés ou
non mais le planning familial offre
également des consultations de conseils
juridiques comme vous
soir à une consultation du cani
familiale et tina discrète de vous
demander pourquoi place et à petits pas
discret évidemment enfin c'est le fait
que mon mari m'a abandonnée et j'ai eu
des problèmes à résoudre
en dommage on avait pas beaucoup de
connaissances et j'ai rencontré une
personne qui était conseillère conjugale
qui m'a conseillé de venir au plein et
qui va donner l'adresse de la rue jj
yens c'est la première fois que vous
venez fille non c'est pas la première
fois ça fait déjà un an que je suis
affilié
il ya aussi ici des conseillères
familiale vous estimez définit alors les
conseillères familiales sont des
assistants qui ont bien sûr de prolonger
leur formation pour pouvoir être apte à
recevoir les personnes qui en font la
demande d'être aidés sur le plan de
leurs conflits conjugaux
sur le plan des problèmes sexuels sur le
plan de
de tout ce qui est au niveau des
relations entre les personnes et la
conseillère reçoit ces personnes pour
essayer de les aider à prendre
conscience de leur situation à éclairer
leurs problèmes à les aider dans la
mesure du possible à devenir plus adulte
c'est à dire être capable de justement
de faire mieux face aux problèmes qui se
présentent à eux
nous avons un rôle assez difficile à
définir par rapport à ce qui existe déjà
c'est à dire par rapport aux
psychologues par rapport aux psychiatres
psychanalystes nous sommes évidemment
nous n'avons pas la même formation
mais nous aidons les gens selon un style
un peu différent et bien entendu notre
travail se fait aussi en collaboration
avec ses différents spécialistes
auxquels les gens on t'a peuvent
s'adresser selon le moment de se trouver
veulent choisir justement quelquefois de
après avoir une conseillère de devoir un
autre spécialiste ou alors la démarche
est inverse
il y avait beaucoup de personnes tout à
l'heure dans la salle détente et
pourtant aucune où pratiquement aucune
ne voulu répondre à mes questions
à quoi cela peut-il correspondre à votre
avis bien je pense que les gens fassent
état dès que je pense qu'elle de
problème il ya les gens qui entendent
maintenant de plus en plus parler enfin
de sexualité de pilule de contraception
on en parle beaucoup en ce moment par
exemple on peut en parler à la radio
dans les journaux en parlent jour par
exemple de l'érotisation delà de la
publicité dans ce sont des choses qui
semblent entrées dans les moeurs
et finalement on s'aperçoit que ce n'est
pas aussi simple que cela et que
beaucoup de personnes enfin pense que
c'est encore un sujet qui est à bout et
que elles ne peuvent pas parler devant
des caméras d'une question qui leur
semble encore très personnel est entouré
peut-être d'un certain mystère en tout
cas peut-être aussi d'une certaine
culpabilité
madame audibert secrétaire générale du
planning familial pour la région
parisienne
les liens ne l'a jamais aidé malthusien
le planning familial n'a jamais été
contre les familles nombreuses
lorsque les parents désirent beaucoup
d'enfants le planning familial estime
que chaque couple doit pouvoir décider
du nombre d'enfants qu'ils désirent
la pilule est très contestée
actuellement est ce que vous observez
une certaine perturbation parmi les
femmes qui viennent nous voir
oui ces derniers temps nous avons eu en
tout cas particulier pas mal de coups de
téléphone de personnes prenant des
pilules et un petit peu affolés par tous
contents disait dans la presse nous les
renvoyons toujours vers leur médecin
nous estimons qu'il ne faut pas
s'affoler inutilement mais vous savez qu
au planning la pilule n'est pas la seule
méthode contraceptive que nous
préconisions et l'avenir du planning
familial
l'avenir dépend des décrets
d'application qui vont paraître
incessamment paraît-il il est question
de créer des centres d'information
familiale nous espérons y avoir notre
place
ça dépend du gouvernement